[Music]
Call of Duty is coming out this year
would you believe it mr. Chris waters
and Rob handler II you guys played it
black ops 3 they teased it out really
badly there for a while as if everyone
didn't realize it was black ops 3 short
on the media dead set and you guys went
down to the Star Wars majiggy and some
reason they were also showing for Call
of Duty well we had to go five across
the breadth of LA to get there but yet
okay Roy York okay so let me know what's
going on black ops 3 getting even close
as if titanfall Call of Duty run close
enough to just trying to merge them back
together there's this fella
we'll see you back home soon enough it
was going on now titanfall is got that
wall running that momentum thing going
on and advanced warfare is over here
with the like kittens just waiting look
really quickly yeah what if we just
right in the middle somewhere
so this was straight-up godlike war
running and popping around and jetpack
stuff again yes so it's got traversal
stuff basically there's like a thrust
jump and it's like it can use it you can
use it like a double jump but it's like
a double jump with an energy bar so it's
it's a controlled metered thing right
and you can kind of go left and right
it's all I got a flow yeah yes if you're
like you're tapping right you up and you
tap the sort of float yeah
but the main thing that I kind of took
away was like it's a traversal fluidity
thing we're no longer you like
constantly like pushing a to climb a
wall and all this stuff it's like your
initial jump and then as long as you're
facing in the direction of where you're
trying to go you just kind of flew it
over there yeah you just waste clamber
through so you you know you clear easily
clamber over a windowsill and even now
backwards you can move backwards and do
as well as have your gun all the way
they're always up yeah this week so how
does it feel how different does it feel
to about whoever so it feels I mean and
this was the bank chair the drum track
was banging the whole time we were there
is that fluidity is that guns up thing
and it does feel more fluid I mean you
feel like you have a certain kind of
flow through the the map and the
distinction I drew with
titanfall and advanced warfare was
titanfall you're sort of moving in
concert with the map whereas in advanced
warfare you're sort of you're just
darting around the map within your own
little like abilities you don't really
have to necessarily know which how
this wall extends and whether it curves
in order to like successfully navigate
it yeah so it's a little bit more of
that environmental awareness and that
like you know just moving around the map
is not only like a stunt in of itself
but also kind of satisfying so it's not
as if you're like because the thing in
sight involve is very much like you have
to get from the spawn point to where the
action is we're gonna try and make it as
quick as possible if you do that right
this is the lane so is it less it's less
about like covering a lot large pieces
of ground no this is still called duty
size Maps so like even if you're just
running you know normally you're gonna
get into the action very quickly and
then you know they've got also got this
sort of like power slide which just
dashes you forward in a slide position
and a couple others in like they're
swimming now but yeah so needed you know
yeah it definitely still feels I mean
there you see the titanfall shot yeah
right and like while running and
shooting dudes it still did it didn't
make it means it's not cool for other
people to do it and it's still fun to do
but yet there is that kind of fluidity
that is a nice contrast to the abrupt
and horrible death that often before
yeah you in Call of Duty okay so you
guys played it for a little while
obviously this is super early games not
for another six months at least we'll
probably see a lot more at e3 and just
before we wrap it up what are your sort
of initial impressions on this
comparison to last year's Rob was
reading about this you preferred to
advanced warfare yeah I mean I'm as far
as my play style goes like I just love
being frantic and running around which
is why titanfall and advanced warfare
we're pretty appealing but this is yeah
it's more to tone down it's not as like
glitchy right like advanced warfare is
always like these combo moves and being
taken on by surprise this felt a lot
more like let's prolong the fight like
there's for instance another thing they
completely omitted was no longer can I
stab you once with a knife like if we're
close enough yes it's a gun but as
opposed to like dying in social doesn't
kids and develop melee yes let's
basically push back and like have some
more fun oh cool all right I like that
yeah and I I mean this is sort of this
weird scenario for me every years like I
enjoy playing call of duty at press
events I get psyched for it to release
and then I play it
we release for like a week yeah and then
I get them onto something else
where's you played like titanfall
involved for a long time you play for
months yeah it's that's not my way with
multiplayer shooters in general yes it
happens to be with Call of Duty so I'm
intrigued I feel like it's sort of
carving out a dis ting niche among this
sort of trend of much more mobility and
shooters that we're seeing in the games
we've mentioned Plus Halo 5 etc etc I'm
excited to see where it where it lands
and how it feels but it seems promising
cool alright thanks gentlemen for
telling us all about that I'm sure we'll
have more impressions on the site over
the next couple of weeks all the way up
to e3
[Music]